I don't want to spend a ton of time on this today,
but I got a bunch of emails from people since
Joe Biden was sworn in about what is likely to
happen from the standpoint of Donald Trump second
impeachment trial, which we still don't know when
it will actually take place. But I think it makes
sense, just as a reminder that, yes, Donald Trump
was impeached a second time before leaving office
in the House of Representatives. Yes, it will
be up to the Senate to vote to either convict
or acquit in a trial that is going to take place
at some point in time. And it bears mentioning
that Republican support for convicting Donald
Trump in the Senate trial grew over the last
few days of Trump's administration and during the
first few days of Joe Biden's. There's a Politico
morning consult poll released earlier this week
where about 20 percent of Republicans now say they
either strongly or somewhat approve of conviction
of Donald Trump. That's up from the previous poll
where only 14 percent of Republicans said the
same thing. So support for a conviction among
Republican voters is up, but most Republicans
are still against conviction. And, of course,
it remains to be seen to what degree Republicans
continue to stand behind the now former president
Donald Trump. It's very partizan. Still, 86
percent of Democrats approve of a conviction,
50 percent of independents strongly or somewhat
approve of a conviction, and again, 20 percent of
Republicans. But really what it's going to come
down to are Republican senators and it is mere
speculation at this point. Would Mitt Romney
vote to convict? Mitt Romney voted to convict
on one of two counts in Donald Trump's first
impeachment trial. Mitch McConnell reportedly
was pleased with the impeachment of Trump,
meaning what the House of Representatives did,
presumably believed to be because it allowed
the Republican Party to try to create
distance between itself and the then outgoing, now
former president. But just because Mitch McConnell
is pleased that Trump was impeached in the House
doesn't mean Mitch McConnell has any plan to vote
to convict during the Senate impeachment trial
of Donald Trump. So it simply has to happen now
a few just very, very basic ideas about this.
Some have floated the idea that we forget about
the impeachment trial. I think this would be
a disaster if you do a if the House impeaches,
they did it because they felt they had to.
That's the way impeachment is supposed to
work. It's a responsibility. The president does
something worthy of impeachment. Then you impeach.
It would send a very bad signal about the merely
political motivations which the motivations are.
Trump did something impeachable. It will not look
good if you do the impeachment in the House and
then never do the trial. I think that that would
be an absolute disaster. And it opens up the door
to impeachment becoming a much more political
thing. You know, when Marjorie Taylor Green, that
kooky kuhnen congresswoman, said, I'm going to
write up articles of impeachment for Joe Biden
before Biden was even sworn in, that's the type of
stuff that will start to see more on the level of
what happened to Donald Trump in the House a week
and a half ago. If there is no trial, there must
be a trial. The full process must take place in
terms of when I actually think sooner is better. I
think the longer you wait, the more the the lower
the chance of a conviction goes. So I would like
to see it soon. The Senate can walk and chew
gum at the same time. Joe Biden can get things
done even while an impeachment trial is going
on. That's my view. I'd love to hear from you.